well you've been hearing about this for  months this afternoon it's official the  name of our airport has changed mccarran  international is now harry reid  international about an hour ago a  celebration was held county  commissioners approved the name change  earlier this year and private donors  paid for it commissioners say the name  change helps represent nevada today  he was tireless at his work  but he grew up with one foot in  searchlight and came here and represents  really modern nevada and so when you fly  into this airplane airport now you're  going to hear harry reid and you're  going to realize this is the new nevada  this is the matter that everybody around  the world represents  well the name change is an effort by the  county to distance itself from the pat  mccarran name the former senator had a  history of racism the airport will keep  its faa designation l-a-s